bienvenidos a la presentación de
división nivel 4 ya estamos grandes ya
estamos en el nivel 4 ahora que hace a
la división nivel 4 más difícil que la
división del nivel 3 o nivel 2
bueno aquí aquí en lugar de dividir
entre un dígito vamos a dividir entre
dos dígitos entonces vamos a iniciar con
unos ejercicios ahora vas a ver que es
relativamente es lo mismo
bueno no es un poco difícil pero no te
asustes no no cambies el vídeo vamos a
iniciar con qué te parece 25 vamos a
dividir el número 6 1250 entre 25 ajá
perfecto ahora lo primero que haces es
preguntarte a el 25 tenemos 25 el 25
cabe en 6 no verdad no caben 6 25 es
mucho mayor que 6 entonces sigues sigues
con otro dígito 25 caben 62 en 62
en efecto 62 es mayor que 25 ahora
tantas veces cada 25 en 62 25 por 1 es
igual a 25 25 por 12 es igual a 50 por
lo tanto 25 café en 62 mínimo dos veces
ahora 25 por 3 es igual a 75 decir eso
ya es demasiado por lo tanto aquí
solamente cabe dos veces ahora no hay
una manera mecánica de hacer esto porque
por ejemplo tienes que pensar cuántas
veces cabría preguntarse cuántas veces
cabe este número en tal número porque
puedes poner aquí el 33 por 25 es igual
a 75 75 pongo aquí abajo y me queda un
número mucho más grande así que tendría
que regresar al número 2 o de igual
manera por ejemplo ok en lugar del 2 yo
pongo el 11 por 25 es igual a 25 y el
residuo me queda un número mayor que 25
entonces eso me indica que cabe otro 25
espero no haberse confundido simplemente
es cierto o sea tienes que hacerlo como
al tanteo
tienes que estar adivinando los números
y tal vez digas o ahí no nos sale esto
pero a todo el mundo le pasa si te
contara cada anécdota mía pero sigamos
ok 2562
dos veces entonces 2 por 25 es igual a 2
por 5 es igual a 10 entonces 2 por 2 es
más uno es igual a 55 aquí ahora 2 por
25 es igual a 50 y ahora resta 2 ahora
restamos 2 -0 es igual a 26 menos 5 es
igual a 1 tenemos 12 y ahora bajamos
este 5 y como puedes ver aquí ya la
mecánica es lo mismo casi lo mismo que
en el nivel 3 pero seguimos 25 cuántas
veces cabe en 125 pensamos 25 cabe en
100 aproximadamente 4 veces cierto 4
veces ahora en 125 sería una vez más
entonces 5 veces y si no estás seguro de
eso intentarlo con 4 y vas a ver que te
va a sobrar o si lo intentas con 6 va a
saber que que 6 por 25 es un número
mucho mayor que 125 así que no puedes
usar el 6 por lo tanto 25 cabe en 125 5
veces multiplicamos 5 por 5 es igual a
25 aquí pongo el 5 y el 2 sacar
5 x 2 es igual a 10 10 + 2 es igual a 12
exacto es exacto 125 225 es igual a 0 y
bajamos este otro 0 ahora a 25 caben 0
en 0 cuántas veces 0 cierto entonces
tenemos un residuo cero por lo tanto 25
cabe en 6.250 exactamente 250 veces
hagamos hagamos otro ejemplo hagamos
otro ejemplo parecido a este aquí borrón
muy bien ok voy a pensar un número
interesante un número interesante tal
vez el 15 el 15 aunque no sé que tenga
de especial ese número pero bueno el 15
cuántas veces cabe en el 2.265 2.265
hacemos lo mismo lo mismo lo mismo en el
ejemplo anterior 15 cuántas veces cabe
en el 2
ninguna vez cierto pero en el 22 y en el
22 cabe una vez aquí pongo el 1 arriba
de este 2 porque cabe en el 22 entonces
ahora
tengo 1 por 15 es igual a 15 pongo el 15
aquí abajo y después hago la resta aquí
voy a quitarle a este y le pongo aquí a
este que da 12 12 menos 5 es igual a 7 y
ahora bajo el 6 ok entonces tenemos 76
cuántas veces cabe el 15 en el 76
tenemos que pensemos en esto porque ok
piensa 15 por 2 es igual a 30 15 por 4
es igual a 60 15 por 5 es igual a 75
parece que ese es el indicado cierto 15
15 cabe en 76 5 veces ajá
ahora multiplico 5 por 5 es igual a 25 5
por 1 es igual a 57 es igual a 12 y no
aquí ya me equivoqué si ves que me
equivoqué me equivoqué porque más bien
es es 25 5 por 5 es igual a 25
ahora 5 por 1 es igual a 5 + 2 es igual
ahora sí ya está todo bien tranquilos no
pasa nada la vida sigue la vida fluye
ahora tenemos aquí 15 15 caben quince
exactamente exactamente una vez una vez
ahora uno por quince es igual a quince
pongo el quince aquí abajo y restamos
quince menos quince es igual a cero y
prácticamente ya acabamos por lo tanto
el 15 cabe en 2.265 exactamente 151
veces ahora ok observar qué está pasando
aquí estamos dividiendo entre un número
de dos dígitos es diferente a cuando
dividimos entre un dígito aquí está un
poco más difícil porque no todo mundo
sabe las tablas de del 12 del 13 del 15
del 25 no todo el mundo se la sabe de
hecho muy pocas personas entonces aquí
aquí trabajamos por prueba y error ajá
simplemente
dices un número lo multiplicas los
restas y ves si funciona ok voy a pensar
en números para este otro ejemplo que
vamos a hacer a continuación
pensaron números que tal vez números que
tal vez no me den un residuo exacto ok
que te parece
67 cuántas veces caben 5.978 pensemos en
esto y ahora aquí es como te digo por
prueba y error me puedo equivocar
fácilmente
pensamos pensemos simplemente 67
cuántas veces caben 50 veces seguimos 67
cuántas veces caben 50 y 90 veces 67
cuántas veces caben 597 ahí ahí está el
el truco no lo que da miedo 67 es casi
70 y 597 es casi 670 por 9 es igual a
630 se pasa por un poquito así que yo
digo yo yo digo que aproximadamente cabe
ocho veces veamos si es cierto veamos
vamos a intentarlo vamos a multiplicar
aquí vamos a ver si estamos
67 por 8 8 por 7 es igual a 56 pongo el
6 aquí y llevamos 5 ahora 8 por 6 es
igual a 48 más 5 es igual a 53 53 ahora
restamos restamos 7 menos seis es igual
a 19 menos tres es igual a 6 655 es
igual a 0 excelente lo que tengo aquí es
está bien porque porque 61 es menor que
67 así yo obtengo aquí un número mayor
67 quiere decir que este número el 8 no
es lo suficientemente grande pero como
aquí tengo un número positivo y 61 es
menor que 67 estamos bien estamos en lo
correcto ahora bajamos este 8 aquí que
si tenemos 67 es casi 70 y acá tenemos
casi 630 así que esta vez puede ser que
si caben 9 veces no lo sé puede que
pueda vamos a intentarlo con 9 entonces
multiplicamos 9 por 7 es igual a 63
9 x 6 es igual a 54 6 es igual a 60 bien
perfecto aquí puedes ver que si caben 9
veces porque 603 es menor que 618
hacemos la resta aquí tenemos 5 aquí 10
es 1 y 6 menos 6 es igual a 0 por lo
tanto tenemos un residuo de 15 y 15 es
menor que 67 entonces como no te estoy
enseñando por este momento decimales lo
vamos a dejar así y entonces tenemos el
resultado que 67 cabe 89 cc en 5 1978 y
tenemos un residuo de 15 ahora intenta
tu división es de nivel 4 y diviértete
nos vemos